let's do this yes sir I'm excited all
right Chris and Clay
the man himself
Chris and Clay so you guys have been
friends for how long uh forever forever
yeah you're 19 and 20 years old yeah
we're neighbors we grew up 20. I I uh my
birthday was January 17th yeah
you forgot your birthday yeah I turned
20 in October yeah
can you guys live where uh neighbors
yeah Trenton New Jersey Trenton New
Jersey yeah what's it like living in
Trenton uh we live we live um like on
the outside like so we're in the
Suburban area yeah it's it's not now
yeah your families are cool yeah
yeah
my family I'm saying uh it's definitely
cool on the outside on the outside right
there's stuff going on at home that
makes you well my dad right now has
cancer oh I'm sorry thank you he was
diagnosed about
um
2020. 2020 was a crazy year I I lost
both my grandparents we had a friend
commit suicide yeah and then my dad got
diagnosed with cancer
it was crazy after 2020 was effed up all
around
that was definitely recovered was going
on yeah and then uh the protest and all
that right yeah that was crazy we should
mention before the audience gets too
confused uh Chris has Tourette's yes I I
got to rest I'm saying since OCD you
know what I'm saying I'm pretty wicked
boy
I'm free I'm hyper too I'm saying but
yeah I'm more ADHD you got ADHD too yeah
I'm saying how does Tourette's uh uh
on and off the N word about I'm not
gonna lie I'm saying it basically like
it's just like it goes like on and off
it's like I can't like one day it could
be like [__] it one day it could be like
I'm saying it's like a cow they could
randomly change he'll just say like the
n-word spontaneously yeah randomism this
guy get you in trouble sometimes yeah
no no no no no honestly it depends on it
we a lot of bad looks and [__] it's
weird though because the people that say
stuff about the n-word are not colored
people it's usually white people you
know what I mean but I feel like most
people could tell if someone's going
like this
what triggers it Chris it's uh like well
for me I I from his point of view he's
probably like like when I get hyper like
real hyper I'll get I feel like it's
more like if I'm like if I'm calm it
doesn't really matter it's like if I'm
kind of hyper usually when I'm like like
if I'm stimulated like I found like like
people that I love like yeah people
excited quite like friends if I'm in
public I'm saying
if he's in like a new environment where
it could be a little bit anxious nervous
that's the time where you could be calm
a little bit but yeah it depends on who
he's around if he's worked up it's more
likely to do it yeah it could be 100 if
we're having like a party or something
right and it's all of our friends and
we're all just having fun it could be
sometimes
where like
I love you I'm not saying it but it
could be hard for him to speak like not
speak but like to say certain things you
know what I mean like if you don't know
him
it'll be hard to understand what he's
saying at certain times you know what I
mean yeah most definitely I I feel like
for me like I'm saying like the hardest
thing about having sex is like is like
it's like like one day it it could be
good and the next day it'll be like like
there's like really like like hard to
control it's like it's like I I even
like try it's like having like a sneeze
you know I'm saying like it's like you
can't help it it's just like you can't
control it yeah it's just it's just how
it is and the ticks must get in the way
of doing things like yeah like careers
like work like I worked at FedEx if I'm
saying for a while oh they have a
package and be like you know I'm saying
just Do It Go flying type [__] and then
yeah I got like every job I got like
five both of us have been fired from
every job is that right why do you get
fired okay I have I mean as of recent I
I'm kind of embarrassed by because I I'm
I pride myself that I've learned to
control my anger and my emotions in that
way you know what I mean
but you know see the thing will work I'm
a hard worker but I'm also dyslexic in
my ADHD and show all that so people I'm
nice to people so they're not gonna say
it but I'm messing up other people's
jobs you know what I mean like I feel
bad doing that the most recent job I had
is the
because the other one I worked in like
the middle of Trenton with all men so me
getting mad they it wasn't a thing but I
worked with all women at my last job at
a record store
and you yeah you can't be getting mad
like that if you it's women and all that
and I knew that so I just had to leave
yeah because situations like that now
that I'm uh 20. I can't be having like
fits you know what I mean I'll get
arrested or do something to the wrong
person or something like that so I need
to learn how to control it
and that's another disorder kind of like
that's why me and him are brothers like
we're ride or die he said like anything
we could do like if he went to jail we'd
break each other out of jail like we're
brothers when I was at my lowest point
ever with the derealization all that he
was there no one else was because I just
used like it was to the point the
derealization
I know that's separate from it but I
think it's just
I've always been so emotional the
realization is a mental disorder yeah I
don't even I don't know if it was that
because I was never diagnosed with that
I've been diagnosed with bicycle
disorder and dyslexia and all that but
derealization is
it's scary because if you you don't know
what's wrong with you people watching
this will know and I think that that's
the main reason I wanted to do this
interview is because it's not really
talked about like that it feels like
you're witnessing everything
like like say right now if I was still
in it it's like I'm watching someone
talk it's not you it's so weird and I
think I've heard people say from weed
the first time they smoke it could have
happened and who knows maybe
disassociate yeah yeah I've heard that
um like if you had a bad experience from
that the first time then it could like
have left you like that you know what I
mean it's basically like feeling numb
it's so weird because I went from being
the most angry like anything that set me
off and I ended up getting back to that
after I uh got past the derealization
but then I was just numb like I could
stab on him with a fork I feel like I
wouldn't feel it are either you guys on
medications or anything yeah
bipolar meds and antidepressants I I I I
just thought the amazing with my mom
I think I'm on vlox15 too and La Motu
Gene I take 200 grams or yeah 200
milligrams
are you guys good about taking them
every day or whatever I am he's not I I
I I I personally I I only missing them
I I have I have OCD like really bad so I
feel like me taking that is like me like
me like I feel like like the more I take
it he doesn't like drugs in general
where do you live uh
maybe crazy
as of right now mushrooms are my maid
thing can it be some saying before yeah
I don't mess with I've went through like
phases of pills and all that I don't
mess with any opioids I've obviously
because my ADHD and [__] been prescribed
like uh Adderall all that that's okay
it's I feel like it makes my heart like
go crazy oh it makes my heart beat super
fast you know what I mean so I don't
like it but the harder drugs like
cocaine or Nah yeah we can yeah if I do
cocaine I've never done Coke yeah if I
did cocaine Xanax
I mean we're not in college all the
college kids cope if you'd be going
crazy with this yeah but I'm not doing
um mushrooms I wanted to say like truly
I think they're I don't know I wouldn't
say saving my life because that is not
crediting myself but it's a substance
where like I drink I wasn't I haven't
been sober for a day since I went
through the derealization like I've
either been drinking and all that and
that's the thing my parents like I would
get yelled at for drinking and all that
but no one wonders why you're doing it
you know what I mean like if I'm at home
drinking alone like it was ever in 2020
I feel like a lot of people turned into
alcoholics at first you know what I mean
I was bad with that I'm a wine guy yeah
because my my ticks my teeth actually
like I I get more calm like I I don't
alcohol makes you calm yeah yeah it
makes you calm like weed I smoke weed
and like I see demons and [__] he can't
smoke weed I I I felt like I was
what would you like to do with your
lives
um I think we're going to be the
greatest artist to ever live yeah that
is and every aspect of art I think we're
going to be an entity of creativity and
positivity helping people glamorous
Heroes yeah I'm saying I think I think
this interview is gonna
be the first of money put a message I'm
saying out there that's a great attitude
that's what I'm saying thank you what
kind of art are you guys into uh
um all different types music but me it
started with
um martial arts like boxing and all that
that's how I really got out of the
derealization stuff with like
I became infatuated with like the
movement I don't even know like I
couldn't I couldn't feel like I was
witnessing something because like
I don't know boxing is just beautiful I
love I love combat it saved my life it
really did at that time hey man I really
really did he asked me a liver shot one
time it [__] me up he has Hands Chris
could fight yeah real [__] I'm hyper so
yeah my dad's ain't too shabby I'm
saying but he he told me the way that
I'm saying tell me about romantic
relationships you like you're into girls
yeah females are pretty he he uh yeah I
have uh he got some complex relationship
right now but yeah I would
yeah I mean it's weird you know what I
mean they're all complex yeah I like my
Latinas I have a girl right now I'll say
okay but um what was I gonna say I have
to say getting a girlfriend
made me stop being it made me be
self-accountable I always with my anger
because what he is like you can't that's
what the way my my rages used to be like
I saw it like with PTSD where veterans
you see people freak out just that's how
I was I never went to war I've never
went through traumatizing [__] like that
why am I why could something set me off
like that to the point where I have to
be restrained and like you know what I
mean I shouldn't have that anger and
like
with a female no matter how mad I'll get
I what anger I I would always hit myself
in the head that was like a big thing I
would do Chris would see it or I would
just like Chase yeah I always tell them
like it was like because like he was
like first reaction to getting angry
with his head yeah because I don't like
hitting even what even the angry clay
doesn't like hurting people that's just
like he has a good heart I'm saying I'm
saying that's I don't know
even even when he if you would get mad
like afterwards you see I'm saying like
he would like like in the moment but
like yeah like he would catch himself
and be like yeah but um the Romantic
relationships are difficult in this day
and age for you guys for me I I didn't
think I could ever have a girlfriend
because of how mad I get I like the way
I am with them with my guy friends
that's why I've uh I've had a lot of
like
I would say fake friends like I never
realized I always judge people for not
understanding mental health and not all
that but it's hard to understand people
who haven't been through stuff like that
you know what I mean like someone like
you you've witnessed so many people like
that so you're definitely understanding
it's just you saw a lot of you but some
people haven't they haven't seen people
like that so like seeing someone like me
or Chris I'm freaking out if I saw
someone like that I would try to help
them but someone else would be like that
person's crazy you know what I mean
that's why I feel blessed that we have
been through what we have been through
yeah we
actually are there are there a lot of
people from your social group that have
these mental disorders
yeah and and over the time I mean it's
different with Chris yeah with my anger
it's dangerous because I
I say so much like if you I'm disgusted
and done so I can't blame people for
like like someone will do something
wrong to me right and then I will
take it to the max so I'm wrong no
matter what because I because of my
reaction do you get the way you reacted
yeah oh yeah I've had a lot of
situations like that but as I said I I'm
I'm grateful I went through that he's
involved in the person
from my point of view he's doing he's
doing better for self-accountability I
think that's because I would always say
like I can't control like because it
would be a blackout I would be swinging
I would just I would be punching myself
maybe that's why a lot going chairs and
[__] I don't even know how to describe
it the way you know how he said the
sneeze like when I was getting I can't
it's like yeah it's automatic it's
automatic like it's just it's crazy it's
weird yeah once they had a rage like
that in a long time because it's the
stuff with my dad I have to be like the
man of the house now because my dad is
going through the stuff he is I need to
like man up get my [__] together stay on
ten nice though tell me about your
friendship uh you guys no to me I would
say at first like I feel like oh I
forgot about that elementary school
we're gonna be separated me me and me
yeah because my anger I would chase them
Psychopathic like I would have to sit
out on recess the next day he would go
yeah yeah and then yeah basically yeah I
lost all my friends because of my anger
and all that [__] in sixth grade yeah
sixth grade back in the day type and I
started hanging out with like all
different kids who were doing other [__]
but it's funny because Chris the one who
I had beef with was the one who got me
back in there that's what I'm saying it
came off and me I became a real everyone
I feel like it's just because we've
experienced it together that we know is
Indescribable and like we know you've
experienced stuff like that with a
person that you cannot put in words to
other people it just bonds you in a
different type of way the connection we
have is like is it is my brother I would
take a bullet for him he no question
it's like water in like a a boat it just
it floats
I'm saying Russia I'm saying that that's
my boy and they threw out like me having
like take slams like my whole life like
a lot of people like looking at me like
weird you seems like not like like that
kid's crazy I'm saying but like like
having him know like that like what I
got going on if someone says some [__]
about his text how I'd I don't boom
that's gonna happen that much you would
probably understand I would I would get
a little mad unless if it's the n-word
thing and someone said I completely
understand but I'm saying he has
Tourette's
the main thing with the it's just weird
looks yeah he's had such a yo tell them
the movie thing
I was in the movie theater right and
it's like everyone's supposed to be
supposed to be quiet and come on like
quiet and stuff with it and uh I was
basically sitting down like throughout
the whole movie
like I was just saying this like this
like I was like like Cloud hyper like
the movie was like booting up like it
was like like it was like it was I think
it was a purge I think the purge right
so I'm watching that I'm like really
hyper and stuff I'm like taking I'm like
I might hit my head like people are like
I got to go to the bathroom right and a
group of girls go go shut the [__] up
I'm like what I'm saying I'm like I'm
like I'm like whatever you guys so I was
like whatever I'm saying I I we came
back out we finished the movie and then
on be quiet
um yeah so on the way out you know I'm
saying they did they follow me it was
like immature [__] I was I was like what
I'm saying it and then basically my
older brother uh Julian right he uh he
he like you [__] [__] yeah he was
family is very defensive about it right
yeah that's what I'm saying and my
cousin was like yeah like it was pretty
yeah it was pretty wild I'm saying but
yeah that happened in my my defense I
was just like you know what I'm saying
which is how it is but I'm saying it's
almost got in the way of uh girls
relationships with women
a little bit I I would say like like
yeah when I started pulling
what's the most fun you guys have had
together what kind of stuff have you
done the cops have chased a little bit
oh my God we've had a lot of fun it's
hard to say we've experienced everything
together because we're together when I
had it this hey yeah that [__] crazy as
hell dude basically we passed I'm saying
this because everything fun we've
experienced together but I couldn't be
without a lot of memories like I
couldn't get something from a store like
if I'm calling a pizza place I can't
talk then at least that's how bad my
anxiety was you know what I mean
we're the most comfortable around each
other you calm each other's down yeah
100 like his ticks like one of the first
times I took shrooms I was [__]
people his ticks were comforting me like
so it was just like comforting you know
what I mean yeah
you see what I'm saying Morgan I'm
saying your parents are cool yeah your
dad who's going through something so
um
are you going to get into your [__]
after yeah sure okay so my family
I think it's very complex my mom is a
special education teacher my dad is a
computer programmer
so they're very like old school minded
so me and Chris is that's what I'm
saying like dreams and aspirations
like being artists Social Media stuff
like that they they don't they they
don't understand that I understand them
not seeing it because when they grew up
that wasn't a thing it's just hard work
and I still think hard work but you
could enjoy it too I think so engineers
get jobs yeah some lawyers doctors get
jobs artists don't get jobs in their
minds working for your dream I'm saying
guys like I feel like I'm disrespecting
God doing like at this stage in our life
everything we're doing is on fashion
it's passion there's not a time in our
life where we're not thinking about the
motivation and that's that's the biggest
thing with us like
personally growing and all the
positivity that's coming in our lives
right now I believe it's because
first off every intention we have is
pure everything we're doing is good we
know that we're going to help people and
if there's important to help people we
will right but um especially with the
mental stuff yeah
anyone's watching that has takes what
I'm saying just keep doing you I'm
saying this anyone with the
derealization watching this I know it's
indescribable
and it's it's a torture and people can't
understand my mother
she I love my mom she's gonna watch this
I love you mom but she used to say to me
like
you have all this you have a roof over
your head we we give you all this stuff
why are you all upset like why do you
feel like this everything is kill me in
the inside because that's what I was
asking myself why should I be feeling
like this you know what I mean I've I
have a good time I'm an athlete
I shouldn't be feeling this way it would
make it worse but they thought saying
stuff like that would help so like
I think with with stuff like that you
really it's just an internal battle and
you got to keep fighting don't let it
[__] you it's a fight don't lose a
mental fight keep going it's not you
could get out of it trust me the more
you go through a derealization there's a
small few
[__] it up
you got it beat the [__] out of that
just saying real [__] uppercut don't let
your mental control you you control it
stop it stop it
thanks I'm saying hey guys true and
Chris your your parents tell me about
them yeah uh my my uh my mom and dad I
grew up like I'm saying like my whole
life I I grew up there like really good
to me my whole life I'm saying my uh
when I was real little my my uh my older
bird too my older brother Julian he had
a a little addiction addiction and he uh
yeah he he had a stroke right he was
living in Florida at the time I bet I'm
saying I was I was real little and I
basically woke up one morning and like
my mom was like crying like upset I was
like what the hell and then yeah my
older brother got like like we found he
had like a stroke and then uh yeah that
happened and his whole left side like it
is a like paralyzed so he is like but he
came back like at that point my life
like I didn't really know my brother
like that and then he came back like
like when I was little and then like
from there on we had like a very good
like connection if it's he recovered
he's recovered he's not he smokes a
little weed honey
his his right side is like his right
side is good like he his arm is mostly
his arm right it's not I don't know can
he you could use it it's just like he
could fix his arm but I don't know how
to explain it it will take a long
Physical Therapy it's crazy because that
there's a beauty in that happening to
his brother really it's a yin and yang
like it's a tragedy happening but he
came we're all close with jewels now we
never would have been I would say Jews
is the Jews he's the most kind soul ever
like going through something like that
this is the best person to have that's
what I'm saying
it's not a positivity I'm saying are
those Chris's best qualities yeah 100
and any any person yeah he's just
glamorous glamorous yeah
well I I don't even know how to explain
it he's just a pure soul
yo thank you bro I got you a little man
what's
wrong
he's four I am saying his four eyes I'm
saying he's too far yeah I'm saying but
yeah if it came down to like he would
get knocked out but I feel like that's
not true yeah guaranteed guaranteed
yes sir Therese is something that faces
threats is something that Fades away
with age or is it going to continue uh
to me I I think I'll have it forever I
think it honestly only because I think
it's getting worse doctors always told
me that like like when I like like
puberty you say like they're not like
puberty when I I feel like they feel
like it will go away like when I was
about like eight like 17 18 and it it it
has not went away I'm saying it's a part
of them I I I I take it in I I actually
I love I like I don't I think it's
beautiful it's a lover hate I I actually
enjoy having sex because I feel it's
like unique I'm unique you know what I'm
saying it's your energy
Mark remember how you were saying um
tiki Tiki Boy earlier before you started
recording about like the anger
that's what I realized I had all this
emotion and I was like
I sh like it feels like I could run
through a wall if I could put this
towards my passion and all that
mushrooms have really helped me do that
but it's a powerful thing emotion and
anger it really is oh yeah it's it's
it's it's high octane fuel yes sir and a
lot of people use it destructively and
some people can use it they can Channel
it into something positive yeah I think
a big thing is like
using a destructively
I was like that for so long and I and I
always like I never thought there could
be a positivity in it at all it really
just is
time it really is and every day trying
to better yourself and and learning why
you're feeling like that and and
mushrooms I think the main thing I love
about them is if you have a bad trip
it's your fault it's you there's
something you're trying to hide or not
think about and all that
even the biggest setbacks losing your
loved one anything yeah all the pain
that you feel from that you can Channel
it into something positive
using the memory of that person you lost
or the girlfriend that you lost or the
whatever yeah and you make your life
better
it's the anger about being rejected or
it's the pain of the sadness of losing
somebody and you can turn that into
something very positive they would make
that lost person
you know happy make them proud of you
make them regret giving you up whatever
yeah
for the reason I mean he had like so
much problems like Beyonce is because
like
like yeah it would be overpowered that's
a good thing because we have so much
good traits if we didn't have this stuff
it wouldn't be fair yeah that's what
your dad said that's what I'm saying I
believe that if I feel like but I feel
like me having like ticks like like I I
got really bad OCD like really bad OCD
too like what kind of OCD qualities what
kind of behaviors do you have uh I have
like like so it's like my senior year
high school I feel like it was like I I
it went from like me like like Sam was
like washing my hands like stuff like
that like like all right they'll be like
so like like now like right here like I
would say I'm struggling with OCD worse
than my like my takes because I'm so
used to my ticks like throughout the
years and stuff like that but I feel
like my OC is like I'll go with like
days without like like like like
changing clothes changing my clothes you
know I'm saying like like cleaning my
room so your band the hospital if it's
something like that if I had like
Embrace someone like it's just it's
simple stuff like that I just can I say
something when we were walking I noticed
with his OCD like a curve I retraced
myself
correctly so he has to go back and hit
it it's some crazy ass [__] takes an OCD
a collaboration your room bro I'm not
gonna embarrass you and say but he's
hitting on me because my room not hating
he has like third world country like
clothes in his room like that that's
been there for four years don't make me
yeah I'm knocking I'm not gonna die I
know I I know I I do have like Ryan milk
on my room I'll be asking so bad so in
this day and age you know 2023 what what
what does the future look like for you
guys are you guys optimistic about the
future are you very optimistic
optimistic is great I think I think
we're confident this interview is kind
of the start of uh you know a journey a
journey yesterday everything I think a
journey I think a lot of this like like
something like this a few years ago I
would have been like holy [__] we're
getting you know what I mean I wouldn't
have been ready for something like this
I wouldn't have been able to talk tell
people I would have been selfish and I
wouldn't been focused on like the more
important thing like helping people that
have been through stuff it would have
been selfish things you know what I mean
that's true yeah
what's your biggest fear
that's a good question I feel like what
do you guys worry about
it personally I I feel like spiritually
they losing lion I mean I feel like like
losing like like like I don't know like
me not like being to my football team I
mean my biggest fear I feel like it's
impossible for it to happen because it
would be
to not reach my full potential but I
already didn't listen to the people that
tried to stop me and anyone who does
that like you said I use it as
motivation you know what I mean like my
parents um
you can't do it or like that's a hobby
like music is a hobby all that's a hobby
I'm like I'm gonna prove you wrong that
you like they think saying that is
making me not want to do it it's making
me music's the game 100 times to do it
more I know I'm gonna do it like all the
success it's not a question it's just we
know what's going to happen yeah my
parents had the attitude that
photography was just a hobby it wasn't a
career look at you now yeah and Marquee
the goat they go twice
anything's possible yeah I agree yeah oh
and your photography I gotta say I'm
saying top tier top tier thank you Chris
you know what I'm saying I'm insane
that's real I'm saying all right you
guys well thank you so much for uh
sharing your stories I think you guys
are fascinating I love seeing two good
buddies like you guys
shout out to more the goat the main man
okay guys are friends for for many more
decades to the end you you will see as I
see
thanks you guys
that was good that was good it was great
that was great